hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round three of the
super bet
chess classic uh it's a constantin
lupulesco versus anishigiri now in the
previous round lupulescu lost
the fabi we showed that game but now
comes a game that's um
it's really a masterpiece it uh it
features uh not a single bad move
except one uh otherwise you know how
would it be a masterpiece or although
there are
a few masterpieces um like i don't know
if you've seen
uh that game where alpha zero played
against alpha zero uh if you haven't i
will put a link to it in the description
will be the first thing
uh in the description below so if you
haven't seen a game where alpha zero uh
plays a really spectacular opening
against itself uh do check it out
uh but that being said uh this game
really just a marvel
so uh let's see what's happening so
lupulesco opens
with c4 uh we have e five by anish
knights the c3 and now
knight to f6 uh we have knight the f3
and knight to c6 so the four knights of
the english
uh we have e3 and bishop to b4 now
uh we have queen to c2 uh just
continuing development
bishop captures on c3 queen captures and
now queen to e7 so giving up the bishop
very early on but as you'll see this
works out uh
quite well for black we have d4 uh
knights the e for now attacking the
queen and now
uh if you allow black to get the queen
to b4
with check or without check uh well it
has to be with the check because these
two squares are covered but uh if you
place them like queen b3 queen a3
then black can have a very easy game if
he just gets the queen of the board
right away
so queen to d3 and now e captures on the
four by anish
knight captures on d4 and now knight to
c5 again harassing the white queen
queen to d1 and now knight captures on
b4 we have queen captures the
pawn is pinned uh and here uh anish just
castles we have bishop to d2 lupulesco
also now ready to castle
and b6 now and this knight is now a very
very strong piece here
uh you could try and chase it away with
b for uh
uh right away but then okay maybe knight
to e6 and then
you don't really gain all that much and
maybe maybe it's a bit too soon
uh for example the queen is under attack
once the queen moves you can
do whatever you want bishop to b7 okay
you do get this diagonal
uh maybe it can be played maybe it's a
bit bit too aggressive so for the moment
uh he just castles you don't want to
keep your king in the center of the
board too quick uh
too long uh and now bishop to b7 getting
the
bishop to the this very long diagonal
and now uh there
is a game uh where bishop the d2 was
played it was a play between dimitria
yakov uh in 2019 the game ended in a
draw but here we have f3
by lupulesco and it is now uh already as
of move 14 that we have a completely new
game
so let's see how anish deals with it he
plays a5 and i mean who wouldn't
uh preventing b4 and keeping this knight
here
for forever if black wishes so and now
white needs to figure out how to get
the rest of his pieces into the game
connect the rooks and so on
so here uh while you wanna get this pawn
to e4 at some point you don't want it to
be
here on e3 blocking your own dark square
bishop uh if you do it now f5 seems very
strong
the bishop on e2 is undefended so you
can even capture
uh maybe not another way to go so here
lopolisko just goes to bishop to d2
uh we have f5 by anish now keeping an
eye on that uh e4 square
uh for four times uh we have rook eight
to d1
and now d6 we have b3 and now rook 8 to
e8 and all of uh
geary's pieces are now fully developed
we have rook to f2 now with the idea of
either
doubling up on the f file or if needed
you can even double up on the e
file we have rook to f6 on each now
playing to
do some damage here on the king's side
and bishop to d3
uh we have queen to f7 now you can shoot
the queen over to
h5 then the rook to h6 and then you can
start attacking here
we have rook to e2 and now queen to h5s
plant and now bishop to e1 bishop to e1
is a very
uh well a very tricky move uh because it
prevents
black's main threat and that is rook to
h6
however rook to h6 might might be a very
interesting move because after rook to
h6 and bishop to g3
just defending uh against queen captures
on h2 uh there's this
uh well a very very uh interesting
knight to e4
idea uh point is now you're threatening
to remove the defender and then just
bring your queen down the board
and if this is captured and this is the
best move for white then you just
capture back and now if the bishop moves
then you pick up the rook on e2
so you can't really move the bishop you
have to play something rook d to e1
add another defender to the rook now we
capture and after queen capture so we
can
play some like rook back to e6 put
pressure on this pawn
control the e4 square and
we now play this so it's a little bit of
a better position for black whether it's
enough it's hard to say
uh but anish wanted more and he played
the
bishop to e4 right away so bishop to e4
now saying
uh okay you capture my bishop and if you
do and
this is not what happened in the game
because if you do then captures
and now you don't have a good move
obviously the bishop cannot move
because we're going to capture the rook
so we have to play something rookie to
d2 but now we capture the bishop here
and now our knight nicely defends the d3
pawn
and our a pawn is ensuring that this
knight cannot be kicked away so this is
uh this is just uh well this is a
winning position for black
so instead after bishop to e4 we have
bishop back to b1 by lupulescu
and now comes rook to g6 by anish
uh here going for rook to h6 does not
work
because g4 is in the position now the
rook from e2 can guard the h2 square so
you don't have to worry about that
and after captures well now the bishop
here kind of hangs
and black really has nothing for for
uh for this sacrifice to appease so
after bishop to b1 we've rooked to g6
this is uh this
is the absolute best uh and now comes uh
well now comes bishop to g3 so what do
you play here
uh again the the bishop on e4 cannot be
captured the rook is still hanging on e2
so bishop to g3
and now comes bishop captures on b1 rook
captures on b1
and now knight to e4 again uh geary uses
um
this pin well uh still the knight cannot
be
cannot be captured so rook beat the e1
and
now comes finally knight captures on g3
and now before recapturing there's a
move that white has to play because
without it he he will be much worse and
that is queen to d5 with
check aligning yourself with the black
queen on the fifth rank
because now after king to h8 and h
captures on g3 okay we have rook
captures but now e4 that's the point
now we cannot capture because the queen
hangs on h5 so here
uh you have to decide how to go about
this uh whether you go something like
queen to
g6 where you play h6 or you play what
was played in the game and that is queen
captures an f3 if you remember the move
from the thumbnail
so queen captures on f3 there are no
checkmating threats or anything as the
this point is very nicely defended but
now comes queen to f7
attacking the rook here on e8 uh rook to
g8
and now of course e captures an f5 this
is nicely defended here
and the rook might be uh well going uh
somewhere
very very soon and now what do you play
here here anish played a
queen to c6 he wanted to defend his c7
pawn he's upon so he wants to make use
of that
the problem is uh defending this is
extremely risky
uh if you go rook to g5 here on the
other hand
uh this is uh well it's kind of a force
draw although it's uh it's very hard to
see that for example queen captures on
c7
now we play queen to f4 defend this and
now just prepare to start
checking the white king uh queen
captures on b6 let's say now rook h5 and
you're gonna play queen captures and if
a5 and now of course if you don't have a
draw you're just lost white is up too
much material
however queen h2 check king f1 and now
queen to f4
check and you have a draw by perpetual
just bringing the queen back and forth
uh problem is if rook to f2 then we can
even win the game because now rook h1
check
king here and now we can deliver this
check
king d1 now we deliver this check and
now we pick up the rook here king here
captures and now after the king moves we
can even pick up the queen
uh we don't have to but we can so
instead after he captures an f5 queen to
c6 was played
even though rook to g5 is a very solid
hold
geary wants more than a draw so rook the
f2 now
and now comes uh well it's hard to
hard to figure out what you play here
but it's
it's such a such a crazy position
geary does not have any any great moves
here he played queen to c5 and
this move comes with a with a very neat
trick uh it kind of prevents
white from pushing f6 and prevents most
of the
things that white can do so this is a
great position for you to pause the
video and try to find basically the only
move that
allows the whites to win the game while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not pushing this
pawn
or or playing rook to e8 those two are
incredibly
good looking moves but uh that's not how
you do it the
problem is uh giri stopped both of these
threats with queen to c5 the idea is now
if you if you play f6
uh now the point is just g captures on
f6 and after queen captures on f6
you can bring this rook back and there's
nothing here there's
there's no checkmate there's no there's
no nothing uh so instead uh
after this queen to c5 uh you guys might
have considered rook to e
it seems great because we can just
deliver checkmate here uh unfortunately
you fall for a cheapo and that's rook
captures on g2
the rook is pinned so you have to
capture with the king and now
uh well you don't have to capture and
allow something like
queen to c6 check and then you pick up
the rook here
so white might even avoid this by
playing king to h1 but now you just have
rook to h to check and now you're just
going to repeat or
white will capture and then we capture
this and then it's a it's just a draw
so for those of you who found the actual
winning move that is rook to e7 and
really congratulations as you are an
excellent uh
you know chooser of right ideas uh
because now there really isn't
anything black can do here uh geary of
course tried
gear we played queen to d4 and it's uh
it's a it's a very solid attempt but it
again doesn't work so once again uh feel
free to pause the video and now
really win the game for white while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who decided that
now f6 is winning unfortunately it's not
but we are going to show it as it's
uh it's a fun line f6 here doesn't work
because of the same idea rook captures
on g2
and now again we don't have anything if
we move the king then
then rook captures on f2 and then you
can't uh do do all that much
uh and if you capture then g captures on
f6 comes with
check and that's all that black needs
king f1
and now we're just gonna have a nice
perpetual here or even better you you
have to block with the rook
queen d3 and now you have to block with
with this rogue because if you block
with this rook then
queen to h3 and you're getting
checkmated so you have to block with
this rook and now again we're just going
to repeat
this and have a nice drop by perpetual
checking
however for those of you who found the
rook that e8 now
that's uh really just uh amazing because
here to achieve such a brilliant
masterpiece of white had to play
only the strongest moves in every
possible position and this is incredible
of course that's what it takes to take
down a guy like
like giri but it's incredible how he was
able to do that
now the queen left the c5 square you no
longer have that trick if you remember
uh as long as the queen was on c5 rook
the e8 was not an option because then
you could sacrifice rook captures king
captures
and then queen to c6 check picks up the
rook here but now the queen is on c5
and such such things are no longer
possible so here
you don't have a move if you capture of
course this is checkmate so
instead rook captures on g to check was
played but
there's no good follow-up king captures
on g2 now queen to g4
check king h2 queen h fortune king g2
queen g4 check and now king to f1
uh here the if you go queen to d1 uh
which of course possible just rookie one
and if uh queen to d3 king g2 and
no more checks are available or rather
no more uh
you know good checks so after king f1
queen the h3 check was played king to e1
and now comes
queen to c3 with check rook to d2
blocking this
and he was in this position on move 39
that anish giri resigned the game
and a a wonderful victory for
constantine lupulescu who bonds back
very nicely
after his loss to fabiana caruana in in
round two
so really impressive game uh like i said
uh you you're welcome to crunch the
numbers on this one on your own engines
you'll see that lupulesco played
just a perfect game it's uh just uh uh
both him and uh and the diac are just uh
you know
representing their country very well in
this tournament
uh giving the the candidates really a
run for their money
uh so yeah uh like i said this is the
end of um
round three all of the other games in
the draw this one was the only decisive
one and after
three rounds the leaders are fabiana
carwana and the ack
uh hope i'm pronouncing it correctly now
so we'll see what happens uh it's still
very early on in the tournament but
this will be a very interesting one and
for those of you who are wondering why
do you resign
well there's just nothing to do here
you're down a rook and you don't have
anything to show for it you can do some
more checks but it's very easy for
uh for for white to hide from all the
checks king the c2 and that's it there
are no more
no more useful checks yeah uh that's the
game i hope you guys enjoyed it
like i said after rook to d2 gear
resigned uh and
that's uh all there is uh i would like
to thank shane macy as zach for sale
uh friend clarius gregoire schiller and
michael hildebrand for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens
in the chess world so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest your
day